so we come to the part that a lot of
students have been asking about but
which in fact is entirely optional so
that if you care to stop this little
piece of video welcome to it's not going
to appear on any exam or anything but
people have consistently asked whether
how they choose which method of proof to
use among ordinary induction or strong
induction or well ordering and the
answer is that it's hard to tell them
apart because in a technical easy
technical sense they're really all
equivalent so let's look at them one by
one first of all it's clear that
ordinary induction is a special case of
strong induction in ordinary induction
you're allowed to assume only P of N and
strong you can assign everything from P
of 0 up to P of n to prove P of n plus 1
but you don't have to use all the extra
assumptions you could just use P of n so
that any ordinary induction can be seen
as just a special case of a strong
induction would be a little misleading
to call it strong induction but it is
strong induction so why bother with it
well your answers basically it's an
expository difference it helps your
reader to know that the proof for n plus
1 is only going to depend on n not on
the case that are less than n as they
would typically in a genuine strong
induction proof second there's some
argument that ordinary induction going
from n to n plus 1 is more intuitive
than strong induction that goes from
anywhere less than or equal to n up to n
plus 1 I'm not sure that I subscribe to
that but I've heard people make that
claim all right there's another
perspective which is interesting and
maybe surprising which is why not always
use ordinary induction oh wait a minute
how do you replace strong induction with
ordinary induction well it's easy
suppose that you've proved for all N P
of M using strong induction with
induction hypothesis P of M what have
you done well
you've it's the same base case whether
you using Orden
you're strong but in strong you would do
an inductive step where you actually
assumed not just P of n but P of K for
all K less than or equal to n right and
then using all those hypotheses about P
of K you prove P of n plus 1 in the
strong induction well how do you turn it
into an ordinary induction just let Q of
n be that assumption that for all K less
than or equal to n P of K and if you
think about it for a moment just
revising the induction hypothesis to
include that universal quantifier for
all K less than or equal to n means that
the strong induction on P of K becomes
an ordinary induction on a Q of N and we
have with a trivial change decorating a
bunch of occurrences of formulas with
with frawls we have converted and strong
induction into an ordinary induction so
we see that strong induction and no
power above beyond ordinary induction it
just lets you omit a bunch of universal
quantifiers that would otherwise have to
be made explicit if you were going to do
it by ordinary induction ok then why you
strong just precisely because it's
cleaner you don't have to write those
for all K less than or equal to ends all
over and now we come to the final
question about what's the relation
between the well ordering principle and
induction well it's basically the same
deal you can easily rephrase an
induction proof an induction proof just
transform its template to fit the
template of a template of a well
ordering proof and vice versa and
without going into the details of
exactly how because it's not important
but it is routine it follows that well
ordering principle is not adding any new
power or even new perspective on the
mathematics of any given proof it's just
a different way to organize and tell the
same story
and it also means conceptually which is
nice that these apparently different
inference rules strong induction
ordinary induction while ordering
principle there's really only one and
the others can be justified in terms of
it and explained as variations of it so
that's intellectually economical to not
have a proliferation of different
reasoning principles which brings us to
the question of which one to use and
well I can say is that it's a matter of
taste the truth is that when I'm writing
up proofs I will often try different
versions I'll try it by ordinary
induction and I'll try it by well
ordering and I'll read the two and
decide which one seems to come out more
cleanly and I'll go with that one so
there isn't any simple rule about which
to choose but in a certain sense it
really doesn't matter
just pick one the only exception to that
of course is when on an exam or similar
setting you're told to use one of these
particular methods as a way to
demonstrate that you understand it then
of course you can't pick and choose so
finally we come to a pedagogical
question about why is it that in this in
604 2 we taught well ordering principle
first in fact the second lecture and are
only now in the third we at the end of
the third week getting to the induction
principle which is much more familiar
and people argue is they like it better
at least most of them well the answer is
that there it's a pedagogical strategy
and it's one in fact which the authors
disagree with some I'm not united on my
view is that we're better off doing well
ordering principle first and the reason
is that our impression from
conversations with students and surveys
and from exam performance shows that
only about 20% of the students get
induction no matter how hard we try to
explain it and teach it they worry about
they report worrying about things about
that assuming P of n to prove P of N
plus 1 is somehow circular and they and
it's certainly measurable that 20
percent or so of the class just can't
reliably do proofs by induction
now this
baffles the 80% to whom it's obvious and
who know how to do it easily and it
baffles us instructors we can't figure
out what the problem is that those 20%
have and we've been trying to teach
induction lots of different ways on the
other hand nobody has trouble believing
the well ordering principle and working
with it and it certainly certainly don't
have any harder time using it than they
do using ordinary induction or strong
induction and this conceptual problem
about is it safe and do I really believe
and it just doesn't come up with the
well ordering principle everybody agrees
that it's obvious that a non-negative
set of a non-empty set of non-negative
integers is going to have a least one
and so we chose to do well ordering
right away because there's no overhead
in explaining it and it lets us get
going on interesting proofs from the
get-go as opposed to waiting a while or
spending a couple of lectures working
through induction and leaving that with
the main if only method that people have
for proving things about non-negative
integers